este encuentro con estos dos grupos que
realizaron esta incursión en territorio
ruso desde el pasado lunes se llevó a
cabo en una región no muy lejos de la
frontera en la provincia de sumi en
Ucrania se nos ha pedido no revelar la
locación donde nos encontrábamos lo que
si vivimos y lo que pudimos conversar
con ellos es un grupo de considerable de
hombres muchos de ellos acababan de
regresar de territorio ruso hablamos con
los representantes de cada uno de estos
grupos la legión de Rusia libre y el
grupo de voluntarios rusos se les
preguntaba Cuál era la diferencia entre
ellos y es más o menos ideológica el
grupo de voluntarios es más de derecha
de extrema derecha y ellos dicen que no
tienen nada de malo en serlo que ellos
no van con esvásticas ni levantando la
mano para saludarse pero que si tienen
una filosofía de derecha Pero qué más
adelante posiblemente los puedan Llamar
nacionalistas ellos explican varias
cosas que no contaron con la ayuda de
Ucrania pero sí Ucrania sabía y los
motivó a hacer esta incursión ellos
niegan haber tenido
blindajes dados por occidente a pesar de
esas fotos que han aparecido en los
medios Ellos dicen que se trajeron
varios trofeos de guerra uno de ellos
los tenían en esta presentación pero
dicen que si bien aparecían allí jambies
y otros blindados de origen occidental
eran tal vez tomados por Rusia en su
momento en batallas dentro de Ucrania
aunque no lo dicen muy claro Ellos dicen
que la Gran Victoria es haber podido
demostrar que pueden cruzar de un lado a
otro de la frontera y que los rusos Allí
se dieron cuenta de que estos no eran
grupos de papel que estaban en el
internet sino que eran grupos reales y
que esto solamente el principio de
incursiones y demás trabajos que harán
posteriormente